hello everyone and welcome to the second
game of the tiebreaks of the practice
masters practice festival the Masters
edition it's all it has a fusion now
with the white piece against the wid it
with the black pieces so in the first
game if you lose you're one with the
black pieces and now with it is in a
must-win situation and well we'll just
see what happens here so without further
ado let's check it out Fallujah opens
with E for sorry about that vid it goes
for c5 the Sicilian defense is on the
board we have Knight f3 Knight to c6 and
thief and c3 now not going for a for d4
right away actually wants to play a bit
of a more calm approach to the Sicilian
we have d5e capture screen captures and
then now d4 so di open variation we have
e 6 Bishop to g4 is the most played move
here for black but everything goes for
east 6 we have 93 now grabbing the c-4
square maybe with the bishop in some
lines but mostly the knight is covering
it's coming to c4 with a 6 and now the
night especially comes to c4 since
evaded vacated the b6 square for the
night so night the C for threatening
Knight b6 which will just win material
so Queen back to DA to guarding the b6
square now we rush up to g5 attacking
the Queen and there is one game that
reached this position from 1972 US
Championship US Open Championship where
f6 was played that white was able to win
that game but here Knight to f6 is a new
move
so as of already as a remove 8 we have a
completely new game so fallujah starts
with D captures and c5 he grabs a pawn
and offers a queen trade he only needs a
draw in this game to become the champion
as he already won game 1 Bishop captures
and c5 and now he trades Queens captures
we have King characters and rook to d1
check you might be thinking why not
Knight captures and then you will be
able to cast well the Queen's are off
the board that there really isn't all
that much danger so the King belongs in
the center of the board here or maybe
even even on c7 depending up on what
white will play so not caring about
castling we have looked
with check and out came back to e7 yes
for now the night is spin but you can
very easily kick the bishop away with h6
so Knight ft 5 centralizing your knight
here we have Knight characters Knight
characters and now h6 pushing the bishop
back the ship to f4 and now Knight to e4
and excellent square for the knight or
already have it it is threatening to
capture on f2 Knights to d3 defending f2
and also attacking the bishop on c5 so
the Shabak to a7 and now F 3 here future
just pushes back the knight Knight back
to f6 and now Knight to e5 reclaiming
the e5 square for his night Knights the
d5 now preparing to kick away the night
with f6 also the the the dark knight is
now nicely centralized mr. back to g3
getting the best part of harm's way and
now rook to e8 now the King can come
over to f8 or or d8 depending on what
white place we rush up to F 2 here
Fallujah offers further trades the more
the more pieces the more points come off
the board the closer he is to a draw and
closer he is becoming prague chess
festival champion so f6 pushing back the
night night g6 check doesn't really do
anything after King f7 you're just gonna
have to move it back so here Knights the
c4 instead and sorry after first we had
a trade Bishop captures an a7 where you
could capture here but then the bishop
can just go back so first Bishop
characters here and now Knight to c4
like I said also you could go Knight to
g6 right away but after the night is
under attack
yeah you'll just have to move it so b5
pushes the knight further back and now
Knight to a5 threatening knight c6 check
to win the rook Bishop to d7
regarding the the c6 square and now King
F to improving the position of the King
rook the c7 now with ideas of maybe
pushing b4 piling up on the c3 pawn
bishop to d3 and night to b6 now here
with is going for a 4 square to go after
these two pawns we have rook h t1 now
both rooks are nicely centralized and
nights 284 going after the B to pawn
rook the D to defending and now rook the
d8 preparing to the counter White's
rooks along the D file the shop to g6
now Fallujah just limits the mobility of
the black King grabs more space for his
Bishop and Bishop the c8 now offering
trades which fallujah of course doesn't
mind
we have rook address on the 8th King
capture 78 and now rook to c2 defending
the second rank also keeping an eye on
that phone here and now 'if I've freeing
the the LightSquared bishop we have
rooked the d2 width trek rook to d7
offering yet another trade but this one
future the clients he just keeps the
rope here to keep an eye on his beat
upon we looked the d6 taking away the c6
squared from White's night and now c4 we
have before continuing to pull the pawn
and now c5 here if you lose your o
offers a pawn but it's not really a pawn
offer if you captured Knight captures
you can go rook the c2 now attack the
attack the knight here you cannot really
defend it this is covered by the by the
night and if you go here well it's very
easy for for the bishop to kick it away
from there so we'd have to move the 996
and now you can just deliver check since
the c6 square is guarded and after King
was you can pick up your pawn back so at
the end result being you will have a
two-to-one advantage on the Queen side
so after c5 we have looked to d5 and now
as the c6 square has been freed knight
c6 check King c7 now Knight captures
some before and now as the rope is under
attack now rook characters here so at
the end result basically the same Bishop
t8 attacking the knight here on e4
Knight b6 and Bishop back to f7 now we
have a 5 pushing the knight back and now
instead of moving the night
rook to c2 going for further trades so
if you capture the knight of course you
lose the rook so King to b6 defending
and now rogue back to d2 with trick king
e7 and now again your your knight is
under attack and your Bishop is under
attack so there's one move that fixes
both of these ideas and that's
Knight to d5 check Knight 2 D 3 is also
possible if you want to keep pieces on
the board and if you would maybe well if
it maybe try in the win this position
but ok 9 TD 5 check we have King
captures on f7 you could go for captures
captures but that might that might favor
white a bit more but who knows it's it's
a blitz game so anything goes here King
captures on f7 we have Knight captures
and b6 now putting pressure on the
Bishop and Bishop to e6 now taking away
the squares the night might use to run
away so b3 now keeping around these two
squares so the Knight has some escape
routes g5 and knights day for attacking
the rook rook to c7 and not Knights the
b2 we have h5 it starts pushing on the
King side and now Knight the d1 bringing
the knight to the center of the board
with f5 and now Knight the beat you
going for the d3 square we have looked
the c6 or probably just giving giving
Fallujah the move as both players are
extremely low on time here probably
around 10 seconds each and they are
mostly playing on increment Knights the
d3 threatening to capture here or just
if if one moves 95 check winds the winds
the rook so King of six guarding and now
rook to eat you again going for the pawn
here and here but it was extremely long
time and in the final moment he played
efore but before he hit the clock his
time ran out and it was in this position
that with it lost on time
efore is the strongest move in the
position but it's hard to say but it
shouldn't yield more than a draw point
is the the sacrifice the pawn sacrifice
isn't meant to win back the pawn after
captures captures and captures now you
deliver Bishop to f5 the rook now has
the garden Knight end after rook to e3
now you go rook C to check King moves
and now you pick up the a to pawn and
now it's hard to say and black is
somewhat better he's a bit more active
the bishop is should be stronger here
than the night since the place on both
sides of the board but it's hard to say
if black would actually win this but
either way after
for within lost on time and the second
blitz game also is a victory for Alvarez
of Arusha so after losing to visit in a
very short game like we already
mentioned with it already had a winning
position after only 12 moves against
future they they had they went in the
tie breaks and the field which I was
able to win both games and here I have
repaired the standings here they are
after nine rounds and to wrap at Ibrox
game to blitz Tibor games we have a
laser fallujah wins the tournament with
509 followed by vidit with five out of
nine young Schuster Duda adavi Duncan
Antoni Haro in same Shanklin all of them
on five other night so really really
crowded at the top with four and a half
Nikita Wittig of infantile hari krishna
with four Marcos rigueur and David
navara and nil Grinnell's Grandal is in
last place with three other nine points
as you can see below the average rating
of this tournament is 2707 so not bad
for for 16 year old fallujah winning
twenty twenty seven hundred plus average
rating tournament very impressive stuff
and everyone one thought of it it was
definitely taking this one because he
was leading by a point and a half to two
runs before the end of the tournament
but then he lost both of his last games
want to Navarre and want to do that and
that's well he had an incredible
tournament until the last two runs then
it just all he still in the top of
course but it's a shame because he had
he had an above-average
tournament but that's chess you know
anything can happen and and so this
happened but ya know that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and this short
coverage of the Prague chess festival
tournament the masters edition I would
like to thank even pinko Joshua Corwin
me kuvira lineman militants the one of
each and Robert are assumed for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video Sarah
thanks for watching and I will see you
soon continuing the coverage of the Paul
Morphy saga and checking up on your
wonderful suggestions so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day